on joue à Z voldegger ce qui est à
Washington Raphaël Jacob à Montréal
bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir
bonsoir Patrice on s'est beaucoup parlé
évidemment cette semaine revenons aux
choses de base là on ne connaît pas
mesdames et messieurs je vous le
rappelle ce qui ne le savent peut-être
pas on connaît pas les résultats
définitifs déjà on sait que les
démocrates ont fait mieux que prévu ça
c'est réglé mais jusqu'où Sénat on a
trois états qui seront déterminants on
va regarder le le
portrait 48 d'un côté 49 de l'autre et
c'est le Nevada raisonna Géorgie Raphaël
je commence avec vous qu'est-ce qu'on
regarde au cours des prochains jours et
peut-être même des prochaines semaines
parce que ça peut aller jusqu'au mois de
décembre ben ça va aller jusqu'au mois
de décembre pour la Géorgie donc
éliminons ça simplement d'emblée Patrice
la Géorgie on a ce rapport qui va être
le prochain senteur de la georgée avant
le 6 décembre prochain on sera pas fixé
avant ça c'est une certitude reste
l'Arizona et Nevada dans les deux cas on
est encore à dépouiller et on va le
mettre pour au moins les prochains jours
donc pas question deuxième tour on va
avoir un vainqueur une vainqueur de part
et d'autre relativement bientôt ce qu'on
prévoit régional on voit raisonnable le
démocrate marcalé qui est en avant oui
c'est une avance qu'il va conserver
presque assurément ok je crois que
depuis 2020 l'écran réseau américain
font preuve d'une extrême prudence on
les comprend on les comprend jusqu'à un
certain point pensez à la ville de
Québec ça peut arriver des années donc
pour ce qui est de la résonance je vous
dirais ce qui me concerne c'est une
formalité quelques jours on risque de
simplement concrétiser officiellement la
victoire la réélection au créateur
démocrate pour
du Nevada pardon le Nevada un scénario
inverse c'est-à-dire que le candidat
républicain monsieur l'AXA et maintenant
à peu près un point pourcentage en
avance mais ça c'est clair parce que
écoutez ça c'était parler il y a 36
heures il avait à peu près trois points
d'avance 23000 vols d'avance là ça a
fondu à 9000 et on a encore des dizaines
de milliers de vente venant du comté
droit chose qui comptait claire ça c'est
pas compliqué ce sont les deux régions
urbaines de l'État Rhino dans à l'ouest
de l'État Las Vegas donc il va perdre
son avance il va la perdre Patrice je
vais être catégorique là-dessus à moins
d'un quasi miracle madame Cortez masto
la satrice de manquera de sortante va
être élu donc ce que ça implique
concrètement c'est qu'une fois que
l'Arizona il Nevada ça va être concrété
les démocrates vont déjà avoir leur 50e
je vois déjà à nouveau avoir leur
majorité donc là Georgie dans quatre
semaines ce que ça va servir à faire
concrètement c'est déterminer est-ce que
c'est une majorité démocrate à 51 ou à 5
m le dessin des chiffres le le la pointe
de tard donc vous dites que c'est une
question d'heure de gens que de jour
ouais plus de jours vous avez raison
avant que les démocrates consolides au
moins une avance une majorité 55 ans
avec la vice-président ou même 51 49
donc ça le A à Z ça déjà en soi que les
démocrates sont en voie de garder le
Sénat c'est une grosse victoire
absolument pas très et si jamais parce
que quand même il y a si jamais le
Nevada encore là ça va être la Géorgie
qui va être décisive et là on peut voir
les républicains la machine républicaine
de brincamp le gouverneur et lui se met
derrière le candidat républicain
mais ce qui est intéressant dans cette
élection Patrice et que nous quand on
était en Arizona il y avait un groupe de
républicains déçu qui faisait du
porte-à-porte chez les électeurs
républicains pour leur dire de ne pas
voter pour ce parti-là beaucoup de
républicains déçus depuis le 6 janvier
depuis la saut du Capitole qui ont
décidé de ne pas rester avec le parti si
vous voulez et que pour eux c'était la
démocratie qui était en jeu c'était pas
vraiment le principe d'être conservateur
ou pas c'était vraiment la démocratie
qui était en jeu et c'est peut-être pour
ça qu'on voit un penchant plus démocrate
là dans cette dans ces élections demi
mandat c'était des républicains déçus et
il voulait vraiment marquer le coup là
on les a vu c'est le groupe s'appelait
les principes d'abord c'est le groupe
que soutient Alice shiny Adam Kings des
gens qui faisaient partie de la
commission d'enquête du 6 janvier donc
peut-être que ça jouait aussi en faveur
des démocrates mais on les croyait
jusqu'à poyomila jusqu'à quelques jours
on les croyait minoritaires dans le au
sein du parti républicain
Raphaël on le disait l'emprise de Trump
est énorme il a réussi à mettre ses
pions or il y a un contre-pouvoir un
frein
démocratique qui est apparu pour freiner
ce gros plat de des Trump chez les
républicains et voici le problème pour
Donald Trump et de façon plus large pour
le parti républicain d'abord c'est vrai
ce que j'ai il y a eu un frein contre
cette cette équipe Trump oui et c'est
exactement là que je m'en avais pas très
c'est que le frein est venu du centre de
l'électorat il n'est pas venu
foncièrement de la base républicaine
lorsque vous regardez les sondages
nationaux qui ont été menés aux urnes
c'est pas moins de 96% des électeurs
républicains qui se sont présentés pour
voter qui ont voté pour des candidats
républicains ou le bas a vraiment blessé
c'est que c'est l'électorat dit
indépendant celui qui n'est pas affilié
un parti ou à l'autre et de façon
extrêmement intéressante auprès duquel
Joe Biden le président démocrate avait
un taux d'approbation et encore un taux
d'approbation qui est très bas c'est que
présenter devant l'alternative Trump est
constatée qui a une masse critique de
ces électeurs plus modérés là ne sont
pas des républicains pure et dur mais
qui dans une année normale aurait sans
doute voté républicains ce sont penchés
vers les démocrates et vous avez une
série d'états vous pouvez prendre le New
Hampshire peut prendre la Géorgie vous
pouvez prendre l'Ohio vous pouvez
prendre la fleur et dans un état après
l'autre on avait des candidats
républicains dit plus normaux si on veut
qui eux ont relativement bien fait même
dans certains cas ont très bien fait les
républicains qui ont merde qui ont mordu
la poussière à la grandeur du pays à
quelques très rares exceptions sont ceux
qui se sont collés sur dans l'ensemble
et qui ont été rejetés par les lectara
modérés et ça faut le dire avec humilité
c'est une surprise les gens les sondages
ne montraient pas ça et Trump a une
gifle et on pensait pas qu'elle allait
avoir une gifle AZ quand vous vous
promenez et puis vous parlez aux gens
donc c'est ça qui a émergé là ce
sentiment que on allait pas quand même
devenir une démocratie qui allait renier
le processus démocratique puis les
élections
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont été assez
silencieux là cette majorité silencieuse
qui craignait vraiment pour la
démocratie parce que nous quand on se
promenait et qu'on parlait aux électeurs
américains ils nous parlaient beaucoup
de l'inflation du coût de la vie et
c'était vraiment le discours républicain
qui est résonnait beaucoup plus le taux
de criminalité qui augmente dans
certains états également la crise
migratoire à la frontière américaine
donc c'était ça qui est résonnait
beaucoup mais on se rend compte quand
même qu'avec ces résultats là la
démocratie la question l'avortement va
en parler plus tard mais surtout la
démocratie était en péril et le discours
non seulement de Joe Biden mais plus
tard de Barack Obama de Bill Clinton qui
s'est joint aussi à la campagne ils ont
vraiment sorti tous les ténors démocrate
pour dire écoutez là c'est notre
démocratie c'est notre pays c'est
l'avenir de notre pays qui est en jeu on
pourra pas revenir en arrière si on perd
cette démocratie là et ça ça a vraiment
résonner chez les gens ici est-ce que
Raphaël les deux factions les deux
philosophies chez les républicains la
philosophie Trump et la philosophie
plus modéré là puis encore une fois il
s'agit pas de devenir démocrate il y a
des républicains qui peuvent être de
droite sans renier les résultats
électoraux est-ce que on va le voir dans
le duel tram de sentis est-ce que deux
centices va incarner les républicains
plus modérés entre guillemets si
parvient à le faire et surtout pas
triste mais présumé évidemment qu'il
décide par ce parcelle parce qu'il y a
rien rien
mais prise manque de synthèse décide de
se lancer le défi le plus singulier qui
va le confronter ça va être de coaliser
tout ce qui n'est pas justement cette
sorte de coalition Trump donc tout ce
qui est dans l'électorat républicain et
peut-être des électeurs tu peux
déshabiller du parti républicain qui ne
s'affilia plus aux personnes aux parties
Colisée tout ce monde-là derrière son
unique candidature je le dis dans ces
termes-là parce que le défi le plus
fondamental depuis 2015 littéralement
depuis l'année ou dans leur champ est
devenu candidat présidentiel pour la
première fois ça a été que toujours eu
une fracturation une division du vote
non Trump ou anti Trump c'est comme ça
qu'il est devenu le candidat du parti en
2016 parce que le vote dans les
premières républicains en 2016 était
toujours fracturé et on a toujours eu la
difficulté du côté républicain chez les
adversaires chez les critiques de
chambre de réellement s'unir derrière
une figure principale forte et
singulière si Monsieur de santé c'est en
mesure de faire ça il va je vous le
disposer une menace à Donald Trump comme
Trump n'en a jamais vu depuis le début
de sa carrière politique a Z d'ailleurs
Trump attaque déjà de sentis dans un
long texte il dit enfin il dit tout
autre chose
c'est il faut qu'il lui passe dessus
s'il veut rester en ville
pas du tout content alors on va
peut-être assister à un combat de coq et
puis là les démocrates font vraiment se
frotter les mains là s'il voit le parti
républicain se divisait comme ça mais
depuis quelques jours dans notre chambre
tient vraiment à bout les roses non
seulement sur Rouen de santé mais aussi
sur Mitch me corner le leader au Sénat
républicain il sonne également pris à au
gouverneur de la Virginie de la new key
donc en comparant son nom en disant que
son nom avait sonné comme un nom chinois
et que c'est grâce à lui qui l'a
remporté les élections bref dans notre
chambre et pas content parce que tout le
monde même les journaux le New York
pause avait une la une se moquait
vraiment de dans notre chambre en disant
que c'était la déconfiture de dans notre
chambre même le Wall Street Journal donc
ces prochains jours ça va être
intéressant puisqu'il va faire son
annonce là la semaine prochaine mardi
soir à 21h dans notre chambre affirmé
qu'elle allait faire une grande annonce
et ce qui va
annoncer sa candidature pour 2024 on
imagine que c'est cela mais ça va ça va
être intéressant dans le parti
républicain est-ce que je peux rapporter
très rapidement après pour les gens qui
sont moins initiés par rapport à la
scène mé quelque chose de drôlement
intéressant dans ce qu'elles viennent
mentionner parce qu'elle mention par
exemple le Niort post parce que le
mentionner Fox ce sont des médias qui
sont nettement plus dans le camp
républicain et qui depuis cette semaine
à répétition ce sont montrés très
critiques je dirais anormalement
critique à l'endroit de Donald Trump
c'est peut-être du bien peut-être le
signe de quelque chose
en fait ce qui est extraordinaire
c'était son retour possible ou son
retour possible il annoncera mardi qui
reste dans l'histoire c'est plutôt la
normalité ce qui était anormal c'est que
ce parti-là soit encore si sous sa botte
en fait je peux me permettre commentaire
de
d'un naïf de loin un référendum sur
l'avortement dans cinq États je vais
montrer les résultats parce que des
référendums les gouverneurs aussi qui
sont élus mardi soir pour le droit à
l'avortement donc Vermont
77% Californie 65 Michigan
56% pour dans trois états qui tenaient
des référendums donc disent ne venez
nous on va garder ce droit là pour les
femmes contre le droit l'avortement
Montana c'est serré mais c'est quand
même passé 52%
qu'est-ce que ça nous dit sur la suite
des choses il y a d'ailleurs les
démocrates ont commencé à remonter dans
les sondages cet été suite à l'addition
de la Cour suprême donc qu'est-ce que ça
nous dit sur la suite des choses sur ce
droit à l'avortement
déjà on n'a pas assisté à une vague
rouge ça a été une vague rouge
visiblement parce que les 5 États où il
y aura un référendum il y en a trois qui
veulent vraiment que ce soit dans la
Constitution le droit à l'avortement le
kentaki qui est quand même un état
extrêmement conservateur ne veut pas
restreindre l'accès et le Montana c'est
sur la protection du fœtus de l'embryon
là également les les gens du Montana ont
rejeté ce référendum là donc ça indique
vraiment que la majorité des Américains
veulent conserver le droit à
l'avortement et ça va un peu à
l'encontre de la Cour suprême parce que
c'est de la Cour suprême une majorité de
de personnes qui ont été nommées par le
Parti républicain donc là il y a un peu
il y a un clivage si vous voulez mais
les Américains la majorité ont toujours
dit qu'ils étaient pour le droit à
l'avortement donc pour les démocrates
finalement ça a été un pari gagnant
d'avoir parlé de démocratie d'avoir
parlé de la question de l'avortement que
pour eux c'était vraiment les deux
principes qu'il fallait absolument
maintenir pour les élections de
mi-mandat et c'est là-dessus qu'il
voulait remporter les élections on peut
dire qu'ils ont gagné sur Paris même si
évidemment la chambre de représentant
risque d'être contrôlé par les
républicains mais ça c'est
historiquement plutôt normal mais le
fait que le Sénat soit aussi divisé que
ce n'est pas aussi facile pour les
républicains de reprendre le dessus ça
c'est quand même une grande nouvelle une
victoire pour d'ailleurs je
pardonnez-moi j'ai pas par j'ai pas
parlé de la Chambre des Représentants
tout à l'heure parce que pour moi c'est
une évidence mais j'aurais dû en parler
Raphaël les républicains qui vont
prendre le contrôle la chambre mais ça
c'est dans l'ordre des choses pour les
élections de mi-mandat que la chambre se
colore à l'inverse du Président je
voudrais que ce qui est pas dans l'ordre
des choses c'est que ce Collard avec une
si petite marge que ça avec un gain net
si faible que ça écoutez la partie
démocrate le fait qu'il est conservé
autant de meubles que ça avec un
président qui était aussi peu populaire
que ça Patrice on a littéralement jamais
vu ça de nos vivants donc c'est une
défaite officiellement pour les
démocrates à la chambre dans la mesure
où ils vont perdre le contrôle mais d'un
point de vue à la fois historique et
politique absolument c'est une victoire
AZ Raphaël merci très intéressant
vraiment on va vous réinviter
évidemment merci de me rassurer au
revoir à bientôt salut bonne fin de
semaine
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI